ja man kann das jetzt schon sehen ganz
deutlich und klar es ist so da ist keine
100 tage schonfrist natürlich auch nicht
von der cdu ist auch völlig in ordnung
auch nicht von den journalisten ist
genau so in ordnung aber wir müssen
sehen dass hat es eigentlich noch nie
gegeben wir haben kroner krise wir haben
finanziell sehr an spannende zeiten wir
haben die frage aktuell des olympia bei
kurz wir haben die frage was passiert
der ukraine an der russischen grenze da
sind viele dinge die jetzt auf diese
regierung zu kommen da kann es keine 100
tage schonfrist geben sondern muss von
vorne herein ran weil wir sehr sehr viel
tun müssen und das heißt auch für diese
regierung klar wahrzunehmen hier gibt es
keine große erholung vielleicht eine
kurze weihnachtspause aber spätestens ab
neuer muss weiter gearbeitet werden dann
kann man nur hoffen dass man gute aktive
sowie hier auch für die opposition hat
die guckt wo die fehler sind und es dann
nachher noch besser zu machen ja herr
fricke also ich glaube wir sind alle der
gleichen meinung also was die krone hat
es noch nicht gegeben und ist eine
weltweite krise ich habe übrigens keines
aber ich bin ein bisschen erkältet haben
ja auch noch mal testen lassen also sind
wir geworden
gleichzeitig muss ich ihnen
widersprechen denn viele viele
bundesregierung die in amt und würden
gekommen sind hatten überhaupt keine
schonfrist ein beispiel rot grün damals
stand davor den ersten krieg tatsächlich
oder kriegsbeteiligung irgendwo im
ausland mit natürlich im ausland dann
immer mit deutscher beteiligung dann
eben leisten zu müssen kriegerische
handlungen mit dem kosovo krieg ist es
dazu bekommen es war absehbar bei der
regierungsübernahme dass das stelle ich
war wahrscheinlich der fall sein würde
sie erinnern sich an helmut kohl der
jahr 1982 damals auf dem höhepunkt der
auseinandersetzung zwischen ost und west
und der innerdeutschen
auseinandersetzung zwischen nachrüstung
oder nicht nachrüstungen diese massiven
friedensdemonstrationen die gegeben die
es gegeben hat ins amt kam und das
durchgesetzt hat oder nur noch ein
beispiel helmut schmid der damals
1974 instanz ins amt kam als eine große
weltwirtschaftskrise gab von den
innerdeutschen problem damals mit g/on
gar nicht zu sprechen also ich glaube
diese beispiele zeigen dass jede
regierung gerne diese 100 tage hätte ich
würde mir auch wünschen dass sie von
journalistischer seite dieser tage
bekommen weil das wäre fair aber
tatsächlich was die politik an die die
gibt keine 100 tage schonfrist da ist
man sondern er ist auch ein schöner
punkt hier sitzt er neben dem dreh für
den tick chef also jan gibst du 100 tage
schonfrist als journalist béla anda sagt
das wäre eigentlich mal ganz schön also
seht ihr sicherlich braucht auch die
ampelkoalition eine bilanz nach 100
tagen dass es ganz klar die muss man
geben aber ehrlich gesagt regiert die
ampel ja gefühlt schon viel länger als
erst seit heute das hat sie
möglicherweise unbewusst oder auch ganz
bewusst genauso gestaltet die chefs von
spd grünen und fdp wir erinnern uns tabu
war am 26 september zwei tage später gab
es dieses berüchtigt berühmt
berüchtigtes selphy photo schon der
beiden parteichefs annalena baerbock
robert habeck und christian lindner und
volker wissing so damit war die ampel
fast schon manifestiert auch wir haben
jetzt war damit war klar dass die beiden
und das wird jetzt immer mehr vergessen
die beiden machen es zusammen und wer
auch immer mit ihnen kuriert ist in
dieser koalition der kleine rollen haben
daneben tage machen ist und da müsse man
einmal darauf eingehen weil das ist
natürlich nicht störende nummer die
gerade natürlich die beiden auch
versuchen zu erzielen hat nicht so ganz
funktioniert aber fast natürlich dass im
grunde wir beide müssen uns einig sein
soweit das narrativ also wie fdp und mir
grüne und dann ist im grunde egal wer
unter uns kannst daher sie vergessen hat
ein bisschen die verkehrsverträge das
ist aber sicher dass an dem
dienstagabend wenige stunden zuvor
markus söder bereits jamaika abgepfiffen
hatte er hat nämlich gesagt wir werden
an aigner bereitstehen das war
dienstagmittag aber das haben wir noch
nach der bundestagswahl immer auf jeden
fall dienstagabend war klar es geht
eigentlich nur noch für jeden der da
einigermaßen politisch denkt geht nur
noch richtung ampel ich hoffe dass nur
von kleinen leute sagen die cdu hätte
eine faire chance gehabt wenn sie nicht
nehmen wollte gerne aber wir haben das
wir reden hier über die ferien auch wir
reden jetzt ja nicht über die frage
jamaika oder hawaii sondern wir reden
über die frage hat die regierung 100
tage schonfrist nicht und mein punkt war
ja nur zu sagen dass sie gefühlt ja als
fdp grüne und spd schon viel länger an
der macht sind und regieren stichwort
epidemische lage der erste gesetzentwurf
die er vorgelegt wurde als sie offiziell
noch in koalitionsverhandlungen waren
aber ihre macht im bundestag ja
möglicherweise auch zu recht schon
genutzt haben also dass die ampel jetzt
erst mit dem heute regiert stimmt nicht
sie regiert einige shows sind voll
ausschöpft anfang november ab jetzt gibt
keine ausreden mehr aber nein ich glaube
das ist immer so ein narrativ seiner
erzählung die jetzt ganz bewusst
gestrickt wird also die union hatte
hätte die chance gehabt und die union
hat das selber verpasst also ihr hättet
ihr fortan galt damit am jahr haben wir
haben wir klar gesagt es wird aber
stimmlich aber im moment mein vater hat
mich alles sagte armin laschet wird es
nicht mehr was man was man was man sieht
also die fdp ist glaube ich auch von
vielen cdu wählern gewählt worden dies
auch im bürgerhof wird uns auch keiner
cdu-wähler die stimme an den bürgern
handbewegung jahre alt sind aber weder
von der cdu-nahen zur festung nigeria
wandler sind ihre eigene aber ich glaube
wir müssen jetzt hier nicht irgendwie
besser reden also ich finde man da 'mal
eins sind nicht die nation gewesen habe
mich schön hier in der weder vielleicht
einmal kurz einsatz auch darin dass wir
ganz nennen also sind wähler sehr stark
von der cdu zur fdp gegangen ein und die
haben gesagt wir haben die hoffnung ist
die fdp eine bürgerliche politik und
setzt und im idealfall mit der cdu und
da hat die fdp sehr sehr schnell gesagt
sie möchte in einer ampelkoalition sie
möchte rot-grün verlängern was ja auch
das recht der fdp ist aber ich glaube da
die fdp einige enttäuscht und wenn ich
mir so einige kapitel ihrem
koalitionsvertrag anschaut zum beispiel
zur migrationspolitik glaube ich nicht
dass das im sinne der fdp wähler ist
dass er in zukunft die illegale
migration nach deutschland und europa
befördert werden soll dass zum beispiel
es einfacher werden soll nach
deutschland zu kommen und gleichzeitig
auch noch die leistung für diejenigen
die hier asyl bekommen unreflektiert
ausgeweitet werden das schafft anreize
dass viele menschen sagen wir wollen
unbedingt nach deutschland kommen die
wir gar nicht unbedingt brauchen und ich
halte es für ganz wichtig dass man
unterscheidet zwischen einer
qualifizierten fachkräfte zuwanderung
sehr gut asyl sehr gut dass wir aber
gleichzeitig auch die grenzen stark
kontrollieren denn wir müssen auch
entscheiden wen wir nach deutschland
holen absolut genau richtig der erste
teil war nur entschuldigung das war csu
wahlprogramm was ich vorgetragen haben
nicht koalitionsvertrag und bei der
frage das sage ich jetzt noch mal
deutlich es gibt keinen cdu wähler denen
dann eine andere partei mal ausgeliehen
bekommt es gibt auch keine fdp-wähler
den eine andere partei ausgegeben wien
bekommt und wenn man sich die wähler
verwunderung der wahl ankunft sagt wer
hat früher cdu gewählt als kleine htc
die nach dem 30 dann hat die hat die das
ist richtig aber noch weil ich hoffe
doch dass ein wähler selbst wenn der
stammwähler ist sich jedes mal überlegt
was machen sie es nicht auf werden sie
immer gleich nein aber ich glaube ich
kann weil ich schon ziemlich ungewiss
ich habe nicht einmal fdp dass sie bei
springen in meinem sehr persönlichen
umfeld gibt es auch zwei unions wähler
die das erste mal fdp gelegen haben und
nicht weil sie die fdp so toll finden
weil sie von der union zu sehr
enttäuscht sind weil ihre freiheit ihnen
genommen wurde kann aber in einer wahren
heißt denn
natürlich dass die fdp das die fdp den
menschen ein angebot gemacht hat dass
sie den menschen
aber so ist es ja und wenn man sich
diese frage machen stellt da muss man
noch sagen woran hat es gelegen und
müssen wir ja auch klären afrika hat
davon profitiert und seine partei
sondern muss man sagen wir im offenbar
besseres angebot gemacht als sie ihn
halten sonst hätten sich solche
rekordverluste auch in hamburg also ich
bin ja völlig der meinung wir müssen das
alles auch sehr selbstkritisch
betrachten gründig unerfreulich und
gründlich aufarbeiten völlig richtig
völlig richtig und ich glaube auch es
gab unterschiedliche gründe auf der
einen seite
personalauswahl nach einer bin logik man
hat nicht mehr sich richtig klar mit
position in die politische arena begeben
hat er versucht manchmal vielleicht
rot-grün mainstream hinterher zu laufen
hat die fdp das muss man anerkennen im
wahlkampf klare position im sinne von
vier bürgerlichen wählern bezogen worum
es mir aber jetzt dagegen ist dass viele
bürgerliche wähler auch die fdp gewählt
haben in der hoffnung dass zum beispiel
bei den sozialen sicherungssystemen
reform durchgeführt werden und die
aktien rente mit verlaub die wird ja die
probleme die in den nächsten jahren auf
uns zukommen nicht lösen aber er
unterstützt und sie finde ich gut die
aktion macht das tut der punkt aber
trotzdem wären die anderen punkte nicht
angegangen und ich glaube mir hoffnung
ist die fdp auch gewählt worden und bei
der migration glaube ich hätten sich
auch viele fdp-wähler was anderes
gewünscht und deswegen glaube ich hat
die fdp jetzt schon auch ein problem das
zu kommunizieren was da an einigen
teilen im koalitionsvertrag steht dass
ich glaube das problem der kommunikation
wird die frage sein was wir machen und
was wir nicht machen der
koalitionsvertrag ist da eigentlich
ziemlich nah an dem was im wahlprogramm
drin steht und bei der frage
wen wir als migranten brauchen wir
brauchen massen auf dem bereich
qualifizierte migration leute und ich
habe eigentlich die sogenannte neue cdu
so verstanden dass sie das auch so sieht
und er war ja dann sieht man auch da
wieder eigentlich eine reine frage
abschiebung sage ich ganz klar wer ist
denn der minister der am meisten ab
schiebt das ist ein fdp minister aus
nordrhein westfalen der die aufgabe
übernommen hat weil kein cdu minister in
nordrhein-westfalen sie machen wollte
man muss beides tun da sind wir gar
nicht weit auseinander und die frage was
denn in dieser koalition ein gesetz
genug passiert daran muss man erst mal
ich will mal ein beispiel im
koalitionsvertrag nennen dann kann man
danach ruhig versichert zu bilden hier
in anspruch dass deutschland zu kommen
dann kann man erst mal ins land kommen
das steht jetzt im koalitions herrn und
das wird schon die daumen doch er lesen
kam aber das ist doch offenkundig wir
gucken es das gesetz an und dann treffen
uns will und damit scheide ich habe eine
frage nämlich zum koalitionsvertrag
bilde ich habe ja letztens mit den
älteren unionspolitikern dem hinteren
gespräch geführt und da haben die gesagt
der koalitionsvertrag ist eigentlich
nicht mein stil zehnte wer hat dies ist
und jetzt mit ihr immer auf den
koalitionsvertrag verwiesen und die
haben übrigens öfter mit
koalitionsvertrag verhandelt aus deiner
politische expertise erfahrung wie viel
ist denn so ein koalitionsvertrag
unbedingt hier wird eigentlich mehr wir
haben die die ich natürlich schön ins
bockshorn gejagt das würden sie sicher
nie über ihren eigenen koalitionsvertrag
im hintergrund würden sie sicher nie
über ihren eigenen koalitionsvertrag
sagen damit das muss also
es ist natürlich war es gibt
koalitionsverträge die werden nicht wie
eine bibel so eins zu eins umgesetzt der
unterschied hier ist aber dass sich hier
drei parteien die sich sicherlich nicht
so außer in rheinland-pfalz vorgefunden
haben zusammengesetzt haben und wirklich
irre themen durchdekliniert haben und
gesagt haben wir machen die kleinen
kunden model nach dem motto machen wir
die hälfte von dem was ich will dann
kriegst du die hälfte von dem was du
willst sondern die haben ihre bereiche
definiert das ist für uns wichtig grüne
das ist bei uns wichtig fdp-fraktion
rente freecards erwähnt und das ist für
die spd wichtig und dann haben sie
gesagt okay das schreiben wir so fest in
den koalitionsvertrag deswegen hat der
koalitionsvertrag eine ganz andere
wirkung auch nicht bindend was jedes
wort angeht aber natürlich was die
grundsätzliche ausrichtung angeht schon
und das unterscheidet ihn von allen
anderen koalitionsverträgen unter
anderem auch den von rot-grün 2002 und
1998 wir halten fest afrika hätte lieber
koaliert mit der cdu/csu das haben wir
auch wenn ich hätte gerne ich hätte
gerne mit mit armin laschet koaliert
weil ich ihnen übrigens bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen in nrw wo ich im
präsidium des landesschatzmeisters jetzt
zusammengearbeitet habe und ich ihm
vertraue ich tue das auch heute noch vor
allen dingen wenn ich sehen welcher
gentleman art er über die dinge redet
die jetzt passiert sind auch über sein
eigenes scheitern beziehungsweise ich
immer gerne sage gescheitert werden dann
ist das erste mal richtig ihn haben will
ich habe keine ahnung hat natürlich
würde es knallen wenn es nicht knallt
dann wären wir ja alle in derselben
partei es wird klar das ist ja ne also
das ist doch klar dass bis weihnachten
oder erst im neuen jahr ich sag mal so
das hängt davon ab wie professionell
weiter geht wird und für mich war
überraschend ich bin seit 2002
abgeordneter ich war von 96 referent
gehört auch zu denen die helmut kohl
noch live erlebt haben in der politik
ich habe es nicht erlebt das so
professionell koalitionsverhandlungen
geführt worden sind ohne dass was
rauskam ich war selber in zwei
arbeitsgruppen habe gesehen wie das
aufgebaut worden ist mein text
erarbeitet hat das so dürfen sich klingt
erstmal mit farblichen hintergrund lagen
dingen gemacht und am ende eine lösung
gefunden hat wenn diese professionalität
weiter bleibt dann wird das noch lange
dauern bis man wirklich da sich streitet
die andere frage ist wir sind alle
menschen und da werden sicherlich alle
auch mal fehler machen